now Morris on a back in past four Oubre
he steps back rivers will drive off the
glass it in pretty play by Austin Rivers
six led by as many as nine The Wiz came
back took the lead and they're down by
three as we start the fourth nice drive
by Austin Rivers score the field goal
and he'll go to the line
brought to you by your Washington area
honda dealers nice drive by also the pro
level first time they've experienced
that so it's easy to use confidence is
only or not it's stripped that time the
Newbery's going to get an easy two down
the other end starts to drive it loses
it Luke Cunard on the break when
Robinson had this block 33 28 Washington
9 and 25 to play here in the first half
Austin Rivers buries a triple over
Callaway Jason Smith was terrific in
that game went 5 of 8 from the field at
14 points and six rebounds I'm of six
shots for 13 points beyond Mahinmi and
the Wizards are down by three
here's saturon ski with Morris and
rivers same starting five still in the
game flushed from Markieff Morris off a
nice pass why jump
why jump years old the way he's running
Austin Rivers is fouled score the field
goal and he will go to the line distance
in Austin Rivers and get the blow by
there Tobias Harris back in here's
Gortat against me evening blocked away
saved out of bounds it'll be la ball
with six to shoot in this cut or I
should say by Otto Porter on this cut
Austin Rivers beating the top of the key
and then good clean block he has nowhere
to go and throws it away right to rivers
up ahead of the pack his Kelly you brat
Showtime for tsunami rivers screams of
Howard Austin drives puts it up
Spoelstra takes another timeout Austin
Rivers trying to get past ins fires off
the glass and scores his old tube head
game from rivers and Bryant so a couple
of baskets here for Thomas bright good
help from Austin Rivers another turnover
Beale porch wall lays it in its 97 92
strong move by Austin Rivers
it sure was strong with the left hand
and the finish that's the kind of shot
you want Julius Randle take me
rivers drives score the field goal he'll
go to the line what a play by Austin
Rivers and Austin Rivers making things
happen down court oh he has the ability
to do this I mean he can get hot very
quickly nice crossover by rivers up and
under score the field goal he'll go to
the line Austin to find the rhythm in
this game tonight but what a big play
this is wizards have led after the first
quarter only five times this would be
the
17th game that they've trailed
since I've ever seen what's in it it was
not pleasant Austin Rivers drives and
scores and he's fouled on the play by
Larry Nance Jr rivers drives nice bounce
pass he faked it at first then faked the
shot and then got it from Turner his
second start it finds the young man
Thomas Bryan for two it's a big screen
and then they were gonna really get into
a high slump saying this you got to
bring it from the beginning if you're
trying to get the big screen right
that's how you get on there you can't
wait till the lights are off
[Applause]
[Music]
good defense by Keith Morris to step in
there a to gray ahead and slams a
Tiffany Brooke please
21 to 23 from the line nice followed by
Austin Rivers Washington just 7 to 12
he comes in and takes advantage actually
wear this bios rebound
you're not going to hear this often that
was great defense right there by hard
form and it's good to have those great
players now Yanis has become a player
who can take it to that next level
something this young kid
rivers subsiding two seconds to go in
the corner
here comes rivers can together
[Applause]
now internal defect in the end of the
third Austin Rivers bounce pass and then
they catches it for the big Brazilian
for his teammates tyst has to come pick
him up
so Austin Rivers drops it off to the
knee and it is great to have a playmaker
with the bench unit
[Music]
Austin Rivers still trying to work his
way into shape he went down to the jail
a couple games by
[Applause]
it's so good
Austin Rivers good cross-court pass and
he raises up and nice arc on that shot
even though that doesn't spin exactly
Conley back into the game going to his
left and rivers blocks it out of a what
a great defensive flow a lot of time
left in this game
the Rockets haven't get to work now
Gerald Green
become smaller as these other teams are
playing work this rippers dribbles out
of the double-team and puts it up just
before the buzzer went off the rebound
Iguodala another curry turnover
pasta rivers who began with Washington
trade the Phoenix cut inside on
Christmas Eve is an attribute for and
curry
Rimmer's times and side in austin rivers
comes up with another to those 29 points
what a monster game you got 33 that's
this season Arthur Jerkins Austin Rivers
from the room to the lane to the hole
Tucker who is not shot at and scored it
well as the blade passed up the three
rivers thought about it now he'll pull
the trigger and that's good
yeah he's shooting 38% from the
three-point line but Austin Rivers for
the rockets off to a terrific start he's
three for three from downtown says since
he signed with the team your officials
for tonight's ballgame Mike Callahan
Marc Ayotte justin Van Dyne and rivers
stays hots oh man
Hardin gives it up to capela rivers
tough sketch in the corner now he shoots
his three and got it that's a tough shot
with one of the layers times on the last
possession that he got all the way the
rim before the ball was deflected but
overall I like how they played on
rumor says I got you knocked out two
rivers in on Fournier fiim and one James
Harden does a again turnover steal take
a look at Austin Rivers with the quick
hands it's poke check birds coming in
behind so let's see what defensive
changes that magic have made scrambling
out on shooters Austin Rivers still able
to get it up and over Augustine you look
at rivers see the pass goes into the
paint and then as they move it around
the outside the Orlando Magic have to
recover to be better toward a nice Drive
block by McCain quickly ahead Makai Luke
again basking hang clock from behind
those rivers and Ennis were right there
Green kicks it out rivers rivers right
back to Tucker inside
[Applause]
grumpy a couple of days ago and
something that a few made jumpers consol
rippers with a sauce
wow what a lightning quick crossover let
me hit you with agitation go on with
Kyle I'm going this way all of that game
the Warriors played in Washington DC
last night Steph Curry at 38 points 14
of 24 from the field as rivers connects
I'll tell you what when the pelicans
double-team hard is fine and open guys
and you see the double-team coming and
harden again he gives it up off the
double teams quickly finds an open river
and now you down the five seconds on the
shot clock and you're going to have to
take a tough shot here which turns into
it three his team believed them and they
got a good Colet game playing going
right now
rivers knocks down the three rivers got
it to go at the buzzer
[Music]
rivers October gets to the rim goes off
the window he faded the ever-present
Derrick Favors in school
rivers thought about its big score off
the dribble into a gotta get us for the
monster dog whoo hoo nice veteran team
Mike D'Antoni the coaching staff
realizes the tape gotta give these guys
an opportunity to sort of breathe a
little bit especially in practice as
Gerald Green uncorks his fourth three
he's got 23 points now George him to
take the three-point shot that police
say doesn't have the confidence that I
would give got well cut through tight
when Chandler threw it away and there
the Rockets rivers wide open for three
yes mountain pass right to Eric Gordon
what Eric was wild
burries you see the quick release by
Fellini didn't wait for anybody put it
right up ahead
three workers with the steel gets it up
ahead that Chris Paul
Gerald rained in the basket for two
rivers will pull back and he trails it
back to back step back threes one for
Kempe and one for Austin Rivers to 58 to
play in the opening quarter Austin
Rivers with his only made shot of three
here in the Hall of Famer the team the
dream
Olajuwon turnover Lowry it's a footrace
rivers and land Hill y'all step out of
its cool but here's Gerald Green
actually it's Austin Rivers and there's
Jeremy Lin tried to defend it but a
really nice move that green in the
corner rivers attacking scoring plus the
foul his first two points of the game is
Austin Rivers going in and he gets hit
up high and he ends up landing against
maxixe leap
[Applause]
rivers with the interception for read
from house rivers crossover standing in
cement some rivers seas he's got a
little steam up the waters right there
crossover back to the left we'll put it
up
his folks might be watching tonight
[Applause]
rivers back to Shepard before plus
points capella added 15 rebounds 7
assists between each between the
old-fashioned one sole goal is to try to
build a roster that could beat the
Warriors it could potentially be a round
to match up one row some pretty good
names routes and some 7-foot let's first
from downtown as a 19 has been
spectacular averaging 26 points per game
there's rivers when harden on his bench
and his Austin Rivers hitting a three
shot clock at five here's rivers pushed
off maybe on Corbin rivers drills it
that's the second 3/4 river went down it
was critical this has been a seamless
fit Austin Rivers has talked about how
thankful he is for the opportunity and
cross over on Paul
[Applause]
Chris for free with defenders there
rivers on the floor down the hatch
[Music]
[Applause]
pursuit blocks the shot
Thompson black put a bow good job
getting back in transition off the steel
in Lake Thompson comes up with a steal
and also the offensive rebound running
down here and you mention it rivers
who's been fantastic from behind the
three-point line here's rivers gets
inside Oscar who hasn't been very good
bringing scoring punch off of that bench
for the Rockets pretty much since the
moment he got it the ability to put the
ball on a deck and make plays now
Jonathan says never underestimate the
heart of a champion that's the coldest
thing wards Austin Rivers gets that to
go a two point nine remaining what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content